is that fine
yeah maybe the thing is that you can you
can uh
minimize the slides on the right hand
side or something on the left hand side
yeah right yeah like that right now it's
good
awesome okay
so i'm ready to start all right let's
get started so we have mendy from prince
princeton mainly born from princeton who
is going to talk about model-based
reinforcement learning
okay um hello everyone so uh thank you
very much for
organizing this workshop it's wonderful
and and also thank you for
giving me the opportunity to present our
recent work
so this is a joint work with alex
haber and lin young and chava is here in
the audience so he can back me up
if i cannot answer all of your questions
okay so we're going to talk about
model-based rl
and i can do highlight here
i'm going to highlight value targeted
regression
so please stay tuned in i'm going to
cover this part in the second half
so we're going to talk about model base
rl but eventually we're going to
relate model base rl with value
prediction
okay so
the basic framework of model base rl was
discussed thoroughly
in the very early book by saturn bartow
and they have this
nice figure which i borrowed here so the
basic idea is okay we want to
learn to make decisions in a markov
design process or in a general
complex unknown environment and then we
try to fit
a model to data and experiences we have
collected so far
okay so our experiences we are going to
denote them as basically tuples
of transition samples so each
sample is going to be a tuple consisting
of
a path state the action we have taken
the next state we have observed and also
the reward function
okay so let's or we can ignore the
reward part because reward learning is
much much easier than model learning
so the key unknown is the transition
model
so we do not know the state action
transition distributions of this unknown
dynamical system
so in model-based rl naturally we want
to say hey can we fit a model
p we want to learn this p we want to fit
a p to our experiences
and then we are going to use the learned
model so we are going to use the learned
p
p-hat
for acting in the next episode
okay so we will estimate the model and
use the learn model for planning and
estimation
and we are going to use it for figuring
out decisions
in the future so that's the basic idea
of model-based rl
so model-based rl is
a favorable approach for practitioners
mainly because if we do have prior
knowledge
about the transition dynamics of the
environment
then one could potentially make use of
their of this prayer knowledge
to fit the model okay
so two questions
are important here the first one is so
how do we fit a model
okay so what does it mean to fit a model
to data
and suppose that we have a way to fit a
model
next so can we prove some regret
guarantee
for model base rl in an online
environment
okay
so we are going to work with episodic
reinforcement learning
so we are going to have a finite horizon
age
and our agent is going to learn in this
repetitive environment by always playing
the game over and over
and learn to adapt his policies as a new
episode as a new episode begins
so we measure the regret
by simply comparing the optimal possible
value
and the actual cumulative rewards earned
by the agent
okay and notice that the regret of rl so
so this is a super
popular topic and i'm
my list of references is definitely far
from exhaustive
and i learn new new literatures during
this workshop
so so this is a very important problem
and there are a lot of great works going
on about how to
establish regret for reinforcement
learning
in episodical environment and also in
non-episodic environments
okay so now what do we mean by
model base rl so so let me be a little
bit more specific
so model base rl is i think one by the
idea comes from upper confidence bandit
but we can do upper confidence
model-based rl
the basic idea is okay we always let
agents
alternate between two steps so the first
step is
we are going to try to construct a
confidence set
we call it b so this set is going to be
a set
consisting of possible transition models
and the set b is going to be computed
based on
the experiences we have observed so far
okay and now once we have this
confidence set
we are going to use this confidence set
for finding the policy
and this is the optimistic planning step
it means that we are going to look for
all possible models p in the confidence
set
and we're going to pick the most
optimistic
model in our confidence set with
the best value
okay so we're going to do a max max so
we want to find the best pi
corresponding to the best p in the
current confidence set
and we're going to use that optimistic
policy pi
in the next episode for
actual for acting in the real
environment
so this is a very generic framework for
model based rl
and this framework has been studied i
think for a long time starting in the
tabular case
okay so now let's see what we can do
using this framework so i want to start
with very simple examples
so what if we start with a very simple
special class of transition models
so what if my transit my class of
transition models i'm going to call it
capital p
let's let's let the capital p the class
be the class of deterministic transition
models
and actually lipschitz continuous
transition models
okay so the only information we have
is we have a metric
which is i'm going to call it just this
distance stands for metric so we have a
metric
over the state action space and
my only knowledge is that my transition
model
is deterministic and it's like just
continuous
with respect to this metric okay so now
can we do model based rl
so again turns out that there's a very
simple solution
since we only have this notion of
continuity and
metric so the only information we can
use
is this metric so let's just do nearest
neighbor search
so we can it's actually very easy to
come up with this particular algorithm
so it looks like a q value it looks like
a q learning update
but what happens is we are really
feeding the transition model
using newest neighbor search based on
the experience so far
okay so we're going to
uh where's my dn okay i can pull it up
over because that's nice
so dn is the latest data buffer
that's our experiences okay
so for each sna if we want to estimate
an upper bound of its q values then
we're basically going to look for
all the neighbors of s and a in
our data so far and for each neighbor so
s prime a prime is a neighbor it could
be a near neighbor
it could be a far away neighbor but we
are going to
add an optimistic bonus to this neighbor
if this neighbor is far away from us
because then that neighbor means that
the information from that neighbor
has a lot of uncertainty if we want to
estimate the current sna
so we add this exploration bonus to
every single neighbor
and then we want to do nearest neighbor
search right then we look for
the best neighbor with the smallest
upper confidence q value as estimate so
we're
we're really just combining optimism
with nearest neighbor search
and then we're going to use these q
values in a greedy way
so we can see that we're doing q value
update but this is really like we're
just
as making transitions using nearest
neighbor with a little bit of
optimism okay so so this
is a super simple simple idea and one
can show that
this algorithm has a regret guarantee
and however this regret is not a typical
utk or root t regret so this is because
we are working with
a multi-dimensional continuous state
space and we only have
continuity so this is actually a very
big search space
what's interesting is if we look at
exponent in the regret we have this
little b
and this little d turns out to be the
doubling dimension
of the state action space okay so that's
the doubling dimension
of the space with respect to the
particular metric
that we pick and capital d is the
diameter
of the state action space with respect
to
the same metric and one can also
construct a hard instance and make it
come entirely hard
and one can actually show that this
regret upper bound
although it doesn't look very good it's
actually mini max optimal
so what's interesting here is
although we are only using metric that's
the only information that
narrows down our family of models okay
but actually our regret determines
the doubling dimension of the state
action space
so the doubling dimension is not the raw
dimension
okay so for example if we think about
our states
as draw pixel images
streamed from a video game so the real
pixel images could be of
pretty high dimension in their
appearance
but as long as those images are
generated by a computer program
with fewer underlying parameters in the
program
then those images are going to actually
belong to a smooth manifold
and then their doubling dimension are
going to be actually the much
smaller dimension corresponding to the
complexity of the manifold or complexity
of the generating function
so in some way the simple algorithm is
already trying to learn the manifold
at the same time when solving the markov
decision process
okay
another example is okay so what if we we
have
we have stronger uh structures of the
transition models
so for example what if we can featurize
all the states and actions
and then we can represent every single
round state or every single draw state
action pair
using a feature vector
and now we are going to assume that
the true unknown transition model p can
actually be embedded
in the feature space in other words
we don't have to predict the wrong next
state
it will be sufficient to predict the
feature at next state so instead of
state-to-state prediction
we're going to do feature to feature
prediction
okay in this case the
infinite dimensional transition model
becomes a finite dimensional matrix so
this is a rather strong model assumption
but that allows us to do
feature-to-feature regression
based on the experiences so far
okay all right i didn't explain notation
so this is really
regression to estimate the transition
model
based on past state action feature
observations
okay and now we can
customize model-based rl to this
feature embedding model so we can always
wrap around our estimated transition
model
using a confidence ball okay so this is
pretty much similar to
the typical confidence ball in linear
bandit but in this case it's really
a transition model rather than a single
parameter vector theta
and then based on the current confidence
bar bn
we can do optimistic q function estimate
so that's the same that's exactly
optimistic planning
but with a particular structure of the
confidence ball
and then we choose our optimism policy
following the optimistic queue function
updates
okay so and in this case again one can
prove a pretty strong regret guarantee
so one can prove that the regret of this
algorithm is
a determined institute of expanded
linearly
by dimension of the feature transition
model
and also it's of orders root t
so this regret is actually i would say
optimal
in terms of its dependence in dimension
d and the training time t
but it's not optimal in its dependence
on horizon h
okay
okay so we can make this even more
generic
so what if okay so assuming that
my big transition model can be embedded
by a matrix so this is rather strong
so what if my transition for b kernel
belongs to the product huber spaces
so it belongs to the product the outer
product between
a state action huber space and another
state
cuber space so you can imagine that
we can generalize finite dimensional
features to kernels
and although the algorithm looks more
complicated but
it's really doing the same thing but now
in an infinite dimensional feature space
kernel space and in this case the regret
guarantee
is going to depend on the effective
dimension of the kernel space
and also the huber space norm of
the ground choose transition kernel
okay so so far we talked about several
special cases
i mean this super simple special case
when we have determination systems but
with only a little bit of continuity
and also another special case in which
the transition model can be
fully embedded in known feature space
okay but this is far from
enough so let's ask
some harsh questions okay
so what what if we don't know those
features how how can we assume that
the the transition model can be embedded
in a feature space that's very strong
right
and also um what if we don't want to
predict the next state
or we don't want to predict the features
of next state
so so why is that so because if my next
date
is an image we don't want to predict the
entire image
right if we want to predict entire image
we might be over fitting to
a lot of like useless details like a
background noise
or just information that's not relevant
to the decision making process at all
right
and also what if we want to learn a more
generic model
the model doesn't have to be continuous
the model doesn't have to be linear
so can we do this
so our work has partially motivated by
this recent development at deepmind
called mu0
so mu00 is a deep rl algorithm which is
powerful because
it generalizes very well to more than 60
games so it has one single algorithm
that could apply
to every single atari game it also
applies to chess to shogi and to go
so you might remember that for example
like alphago and rf0 they were really
hot when they came out but alphago on
an arvad zero they were algorithms that
were specifically tailored to
two person zero sum still classic game
okay on the other hand there are many
other solvers for atari games
but those star wars are more or less
tailored to atari games so what's
missing is is there really a single
algorithm that can solve all these games
with different natures
and can actually beat the state of art
in each of this game
so moderato turns out to be one of such
algorithm
so it's a model based algorithm so
the new zero itself didn't
know the rule of any of these games
so it worked by learns the rule as it
plays
and then it's going to do planning
using the learned model okay so it's
really
a model based algorithm so because it is
model based
so it actually doesn't require a lot of
prior knowledge about the model
it can actually learn the model and plan
using the learn model
and it actually can generalize pretty
well okay
so we were motivated by mu zero but the
key idea of mu zero is
it doesn't try to do state to state
prediction
it doesn't try to do state to feature
prediction or feature to feature
prediction
so the key idea is no zero only tries to
predict
quantities that are central to the game
so what are those quantities so we care
about value function and policies
and that's always needed so mozero's
only try to predict value as
policies okay
so let's
try to make this work in theory
so we're going to predict values only
so here comes value targeted regression
okay
so in kinetico model base rl on this
in this left figure so i just explained
that usually
we just try to fit our transition model
past experiences to either do state to
state prediction or state to feature
prediction
and then we have an asthma model we use
it
to for planning okay
but now in valuation regression we no
longer try to predict
the next state or the next state feature
instead we try to predict the next value
so the value function the value uh at
the next random state so we fit the
model we still
we still want to learn the model but we
our target
is to predict the value of next state
okay so uh so this is a little bit
unintuitive because
we all know that values are not
something we know right
so we we can estimate values but we
don't really know the values
so does it work if we only try to
predict values
without knowing values
okay so let's keep this in mind
so our assumption so so let's
try to forget about strong assumptions
like continuity smoothness or linear mdp
i say that we have a generic class of
transition models capital p
okay so this class of transition model
capital p
is known but we don't have
linearity or or produce or particular
structural assumptions about capital p
my only assumption is the guang choose
transition model so the unknown
transition model
p belongs to my model class
so this capital p this model class could
be corresponding to linear models
or particular control parametric control
systems
we can also imagine that this catalp
could be just
a neural network models for
modeling say transition dynamics
okay so the basic idea is okay now we
are going to
construct confidence set okay
so we want to find a like a ball and it
doesn't have to be a ball
so a set of transition models p prime
such that those set of transition models
are more are pretty much
likely to be true based on
the experiences so far so we're going to
do regression
but we're going to do regression to fit
values as a target okay let's look at
this loss function here so this is
really a regression step
in which p prime are the unknown
variables
so we write it in a general way
okay so this inner product
is going to be our predicted
value of next state if
we use p prime as the model
okay and now yt the target
in order response in our regression is
going to be
the observed value at the next state
okay and that's enough for formulating a
regression problem
and notice that this is typically a
non-linear regression problem
okay so it's going to be uh pretty
non-linear
depending on do we have prime
translation for p prime or not
so what's tricky here is that the target
we use in regression vt
is the agent's real time value estimate
so vt is not guaranteed to be close
to the true value and also the values
are being iterated themselves right
because
we're eventually we're we're doing the
ami programming
so really we cannot say much about
whether vt is a good estimate of
something so the agent trains the model
to predict estimated value of next state
so that's what the algorithm is doing
okay
so here comes the the full algorithm
so we can make it a little bit less
abstract
so let's say that we have a parameter
theta so theta
parameterizes our state to value
predictor
okay so this data is really implicitly
implicitly parameterizing the unknown
transition model
okay and now
the model estimation step
i think everyone did
okay either word
can you see the screen yes okay
yeah yeah uh maybe just this may be a
good time to remind
yeah we can see it yes okay also like
you have a
couple of minutes uh remaining okay if
you can wrap in a few minutes
yeah and then we can do this sure
okay so again so value target regression
means that we want to fit
our state to value predictor to predict
the current estimated values
okay and then we're going to use the
learned
ceta for constructing
confidence set and for optimistic
planning
okay so sorry about notation i think
notations are pretty heavy here
it's difficult to explain everything in
a short time
so what can be proved
so one can show that as long as we
choose the confidence levels
so the the sequence of betas which
define the confidence sets
so by choosing those levels
appropriately then
the vtr the value targeted regression
algorithm
has a nice regret guarantee
and the regret depends on root k kb
the number of episodes okay and more
importantly it depends on
the eluder dimension of the family of
transition models
and also the log covering number of the
family of transition models
i apologize this capital f should be
capital p
okay
so basically this is a pretty general
regret guarantee for model-based rl
and for a general family of transition
models
and okay i think there was one bullet
which
i removed and this is a frequentest
regret bond for model base rl
and this regret bound matches the
bayesian regret bound
by dan and ben in the thompson sampling
paper a few years ago
somehow that bullet disappeared
okay so now we can conclude that well
validator regression is act
is actually provable efficient for
online exploration erl
and that's interesting because
so in this algorithm we are always
trying to predict
a changing target which is our own value
estimate
but it turns out that this approach
actually works and with
a probable regret so if you look into
analysis
this actually happens by virtue of
the regret analysis and how the regret
decomposes
okay i think this is something that
wasn't expected
in the very beginning and we find this
to be
really an interesting result
and so let's talk about some special
cases actually two special cases
so in a very simple let's consider a
very simple case in which the transition
model is actually a linear model
so the unknown transition model is a
linear combination
of a number of bases or a number of base
models
so in this case this vtr algorithm has a
regret
that depends linearly on the dimension
and also root
h cubic and t
and the result also applies to spurs
linear models so if the model parameter
is known to be sparse actually we can
reduce
this dependence on d to dependence on
square root
d s with s being the sparsity level
so i think i'm out of time so i think
the key message
i want to explain to you is it's
actually possible to do model based rl
rl by trying to predict values only
so i think in some way this algorithm is
in somewhere between
40 model base rl and fully model free rl
and it's actually possible to
get efficient regret upper bound if we
try to predict wrong
we try to predict values but not real
states
so that's the end of my talk thank you
thank you maybe hi
yeah so uh if you have if anyone has
some quick questions for our mendy or
even longer we have a half an hour
roughly half an hour for discussion now
can you all hear me
my screen seems to be frozen uh
yeah yeah so i have a question
uh so i'm just wondering about the
difference between
this algorithm and lsv i used
db my understanding is that they are
different in terms of how the regression
targets are defined
because in lsbi ucb you're basically
really computing the targets
after every iteration whereas here
you're just using the old
targets for regression is that is that
like an accurate observation
or can you say more about the comparison
between these algorithms
so i think they're in some way closely
related or they are they seem to be very
similar in spirit
so our current analysis doesn't apply to
linear mdp model if the model has
infinitely
infinitely many parameters but this
could be a drawback of the analysis
so because i think in terms of the
algorithm the algorithms actually look
very similar
but if we follow the elite dimension
type of analysis
then something is not being controlled
fully so the analysis does not
directly work although we do feel like
in terms of the algorithm
the algorithm looks super similar and if
we apply it to the particular
linear factor model right
right i see well i guess it's sort of
similar to
to this uh to this paper that kira spoke
about
where we basically had to cover this
class of value functions but
not really the class of value functions
but the value functions
as multiplied by the second factor in
the linear mdp
yes yes we then have to cover all of
that and i guess
you have to consider like the alluded
dimension of this class
rather than the entire transition class
so exactly so actually
so so actually in our our actual result
is stated as a lure dimension of the
class
of value functions rather than p
but then i need another complicated
definition of another function class
so i decided to to not state that form
and state it in a simpler form using the
the model family
in the in the regret bound but it's
actually
about other dimension of the value
function class
yes so so so your actual actual bound
depends on
the alluded dimension of this class
because there's like two of these
complexity parameters like one is the
covering number and the other one is the
alluded dimension
yes so you see that the indirectional
bound in both of these the argument
is the clause of value functions uh
i would say roughly yes but not exact so
so
we had a particular definition of what
do we mean by
that class but i just didn't have that
equation here
so to i mean to be precise i just want
to be precise so it's not exactly that
but
very similar
and i think there's a question in the
chat
so there's question about the connection
between fqi and value target regression
so um as i i think fqi
is is not limited to
online rll right fqi is not an upper
confidence area algorithm
but fql is a very generalism about how
to learn from
batch data and how to learn from data
from a generative model
so fqi is equivalent to a plug-in
estimator
at least in the linear case so in that
sense
it's actually closely related to value
targeting regression because
even if we are predicting
the value but we are actually using an
estimate of the model
same as fqi even if it's an equation
over q functions
it's actually using and as a plug-in
estimator
of the transition model for as many
value functions and so in some way they
are they are related
hey maggie can i ask you a question so
just just a quick question um
the the sparsity result is this because
the i guess i thought the eluder
dimension would still be d
but the other term the log covering
number is s is that right
uh yes i see very cool thanks
yeah i think in the chat there's a
question about the converge in the case
of mcts
actually so i have a related question
hello
hello
uh we can hear you i think she promuted
herself
okay oh by the way so i'm really sorry
i should be attending a faculty meeting
and there's a vote i need to be there
chava do you wanna i mean answer the
remaining questions
i can try i mean sure
yeah i'll put myself a meal here because
i need to
your job in another meeting okay okay
thank you very much thank you